presentation Hank we have Angela here
with us this evening through signal
corner she's very poorly and undid but
thankfully making it we try not to work
too much anyway the flight emergency
evacuation required to attack evacuate
the building
would you please leave the building by
the nearest available exit maybe the one
here desperately teri there is one fire
in the room you need to evacuation rooms
have been served by the glass port
terminal fire escape staircase please
hold on to chase the stairs wet also
different form if the only anyone who's
able to attain unable to lose the stairs
women please allow others to exit the
room before they go down the fire escape
systems a 70 point will be in a public
car park to the side of the city suite
is thanks to arrived here please do not
delay your evacuation to creative
collective alliance please do not return
building and permission to do so this
building council staff please note is
maintained the part of this meeting all
the audio recorded can I please remind
you to switch off your mobile phones or
turn them society
oh yeah
can I just raise the point of minutes
when we had a meeting last time it
wasn't minuted that we didn't agree the
proposals we know proposals so I'm quite
surprised but the degree of publication
that has gone on when the council hasn't
actually approved anything yet
we've got Facebook's post we've got
Twitter we can echo a lot of concern
that the wishes of this is pretty have
been bypassed all three stages to no
bending
if you think that's good enough that's
all I can do at this stage will you take
you further I'll certainly ask the
questions Michels made a note of it and
I'll certainly ask the questions
it does beg the question as to how much
jurisdiction we have over with actually
we don't have any way from here - okay
declaration to Venus okay just before we
come on to the main item in 106th just
want to decide one or two even some
pieces first of all I wanted to thank
the working class and the officers for
all the work that they've put into this
they spent many hours here I was setting
in one or two meetings many many hours
both here and behind the scenes to
produce this report that they're
recommending to us
so really with regards to the meeting
itself the first part of the meeting
will be public meeting and will be
recorded when it comes to discussing the
finances and the finer points of the
finances of government we will be going
into private confidential when it then
comes to the recommendations as they're
part of the public document we will come
out of P and C and go back into
and recording will be switched off back
off at that point
okay so pretty happy and clear with that
thank you and just to remind members we
are here this evening to discuss about
this and it's we will be making a
recommendation to Council
I'm sure there's going to be lots of
questions I've been loved to business
with the same team and which officers
will answer but to start the ball
rolling
we're live in everybody so just a couple
of questions so we can get around
everybody and then if there's more time
they want to ask more would come back to
people after that point there's anybody
happy to do that
yep okay moving on to item 6 which is
the apparatus in this case yes a livery
program yes chairman ma'am
the asset delivery program represents a
significant opportunity for this
authorities realize the objectives of
the council's ambitious asset strategy
on pleasers portfolio for enterprise to
present the outlined business case for
this program it has been an excellent
example of officers and members working
together on a complex and critical
project in order to bring forward clear
proposals to deliver the council's
objectives the OBC is a product of the
council's acids tragedy the strategy has
a clear vision to reduce future running
costs associated with the council's
assets generate capital receipts to help
fund future investment bring forward an
optimized asset base that is fit for
purpose and finally to enable quality
service delivery for residents and
visitors through a sustained program of
transformation now members the report
summarizes the OVC sets our next steps
in order to progress to a final as the
case the proposed program has set up in
the OVC is planned to be highly Integra
in integrated set of projects to
redevelop the council's key strategic
assets the program is anticipated to
reduce future running costs therefore
support delivery of the council's
medium-term financial strategy as well
as supporting the wider principal
national objective this point I'd like
to which the Chairman's already
reiterated I received questions from
members this week those questions have
been passed on to the officers to be
answered through the course of this
debate now before a presentation of this
summary of the OVC I would like to
invite the member working partner to say
a few words outlining their involvement
within the project thank you to be
honest members either than different
offices there's not much more to say
than we said at the last meeting I think
we've worked as a group with officers
and consultants in a an effort to
produce a proposal that we feel is the
most acceptable one that would be
offered by members and count and
residents as to the way forward I think
there have been occasions where our
views have substantially changed some of
the ideas and views that both offices
and concurs concerns were it needs to be
projecting and to that effort they say
we have tried to ask the questions and
give the views that we feel that you as
fellow members and residents would ask
if you were at those meetings we also
made it very clear that we feel that a
working party should be heavily involved
in the future negotiations
mainly because we wouldn't belong at the
offices and consultants and project
manager whoever to spend weeks and weeks
of work only to come back to us and find
that they've wasted their time because
we say no early intervention could have
been up how much birthing we've also
made it very clear that although we've
all enjoyed doing what we've done we
don't feel that it's necessarily going
to be for us to carry on in future and
we might need other people with
different skill sets to become involved
in the project if that be the case
so--but we feel that we will have done
our job as far as we can so an S any of
my colleagues have got anything further
to say I think that's pretty much it
chairman I would just want to thank
officers we've certainly had our
differences only the group public
discussion we didn't feel now this is
the right way the information we've been
given by officers what we've learned
this is more or less best option the
best option meet our mother cannot
thankfully the officers and we effort
they quit to this once again I think you
guys to the lady the floor is yours
thank you good evening everybody my
name's Lise some skill I work for called
lead so we've been working with the
council personally to develop the
outline business case and it's probably
worth me just sort of mentioning googley
job a little bit for big league leads so
we're sort of international consultancy
half of our business is brought up and
you care we have probably about 1200
people so we'll largely project
management's quantity surveying and
every business so the bear the business
that I look after and we advise a local
authority and the public sector clients
really on how to develop business cases
financially structure projects and then
procure with other projects so elements
or the public sector were involved with
we're involved with a business case on
the development of a new hospital in
hospital in Jersey the refurbishment of
Parliament's we do a lot of work with
the NHS we've worked with whole city
council Milton Keynes South Shields
Wolverhampton powering it we've just
developed a new civic office pub so
we've we've got a lot of our businesses
is grounded really a local authority
type so we've been working with the
council on the team since last year
really to put this outline business case
together
I'm just going to go through really
summarized on the business case in the
process so that the process that we
follow this calls pages before you are
sure could you turn those couple of
lights off
the process we follow is is what's known
as the Treasury five curses model so the
number of years ago Treasury came out
with pretty much a defined process that
public sector should use to basically
build a business case to get that
enforced miss of the business kit so we
follow that model what's called the five
cases and the five cases of the
strategic economic commercial cares
financial chaos and management so the
first case we looked at is that
strategic is really the aim of the
strategic cases it is to check that the
project that even our doctors really is
really grounded in the council's of
course properties sorts about why do you
do in the project
does it fit within your own corporate
objectives so really what we looked at
so decide to your nervicited we will
constantly work 3 to 15 South 319 and 57
South read the Millerton Events Center
the fret house the Civic suite obviously
wearing right now
so we looked up obviously not a lot of
counselors core strategies and then
check that the project was grounded in
those and looked up I mean one of the
key objectives for the council was that
reduction in long-term revenue cars of
the same as every other local authority
with an eye on reducing revenue costs
and look at me at that long-term
financial health of the council from the
capital side referring back to the asset
strategies or the council has an
objective in that strategy of really
utilizing couple receipts from disposals
and investing that back in the council
to improve services and to reduce that
long-term revenues burned and it's worth
pointing out there that disposal so the
word disposal that we use we do mean the
council disposing if the sites are would
come on the sites
likely from residential or commercial
use with the councilman returning some
element of community use we're required
so we'll come on to what on a site by
site basis book the disposal is disposal
to a third party for them
likely for residential or commercial
uses there's some options in there
around the council could return a lot
for free all of the site or look out
sort of more leasehold options as well
so we [ __ ] up those we've also looked
at and not being too aggressive like
this and we'll come on to in the
financials opportunities for the council
to generate revenue from some of these
sites so we're we're looking at the
development of a new council chair or
new council facilities can we generate
third-party revenue and we've been very
prudent on that so the business case
isn't built on that thought there's
opportunities for the council to
generate revenue again link to the
council solve economic plans really
survive improve in the local area as
well in January in if you like economic
growth and economic development within
the neighborhoods where the development
is and that last point there really what
we're looking at is the council coming
out of this with a new form of civic
accommodation that really meets the
needs of members and meets the needs of
a modern council really and helps you
deliver on different ways of working
more modern and flexible ways of working
so we've grounded the business case in
in most strategic priorities the next
case we look at is for the economic care
the economic case really is built on the
identification of option tax and what is
the problem what options have we got
around those options to deliver the
project and then really we then score
those options from a qualitative and
quantitative point of view so this is
really where the working group came in
and the working group by challenging us
on which options we should consider
whether options should be in or out and
then the workgroup or involved in the
scoring of those options so just to run
through the options option 1 is a do
minimum option so sometimes people talk
about the do nothing option
you haven't really got a do-nothing
option so it's a doomed in mm options
you would still as a funder ado minimum
option
you have to refurb your existing master
so you have to spend money on a system
instead that you've got to bring up to a
standard into mentoring that standard so
the do minimum option would see you
refurb all of your existing buildings
you were still dispose of nineteen and
fifty seven South's read the mill at
another event center would continue to
operate as a leisure master soon from
the frat house and you would reap out
this building option two is an option to
consolidate income some operation on the
fair town so three to fifty
so everything in south africa will be
disposed of so 3 to 15 1957 you dispose
of the mulatto event sensible returned
some community you stir so returned
someone on the ground floor for
community use you would refurb the house
and put a new build on side on the side
of the house really to consolidate a
members chamber there at the fret and
the council HQ civic strip sweet so this
would be disposed party and then option
three option three similar to but you
would consolidate on the mill art about
that center site so everything again in
South Stream will be disposed of you
will consolidate your operation on the
mill so you'd rebuild the mill and build
council chair and council HQ there the
Fred house would continue to what
so those were the three options that we
looked up and what we do is we score
those options for a quality scarf across
a range of criteria and we then evaluate
the financial and half of those options
and that financial impact is a 30-year
cash flow so what treasure made guidance
tells you to do to do long term
financial analysis probably anywhere
between 25 and 35 years so we do a 30
year cash flow capital and revenue and
we do what's called net present value so
we bring those cash flows back towards
long term cash flows back of
disappointment to deduce values of the
more comparable so we use the quality
score and the financial cost to get
what's called a common effect point so
you divide one by the other in the
ointment so the best ranking option the
lowest cost option is the option to to
consolidate on the fret house so that
has at what we call the cost per benefit
point of forty six thousand four hundred
and ninety one so the next closest
option is almost double that milliliter
option three of consolidator and on the
middle acts in that offense Center site
so that's almost double the cost for
them there's a second option and then
what option do minimum that's much worse
so the do many member suffers really
because you get returned and if you like
too much space you're trying to maintain
that that's piercing you ruining the
elation of ourselves as the current
level so in terms of ranking of options
it was quite clear to be on
which option sometimes we do these for
different projects we might end up with
with over 10 different options and sub
options and the quite clause on this one
is a lot of daylight between options
just in terms of the next case that we
look at this is the commercial case so
really this looks up come the project be
delivered so how would you deliver this
project how would you take it forward
and what sort of program with the energy
deliver how would you structure the
program really to deliver your outcomes
so what would the recommended on the
commercial case is is the option of
developing a new council HQ on the
threat outside and then what we what
we've done within the business case
we've locked up what youth classes
almost an optimal phasing of projects so
obviously you've got an issue area where
he will be deep hunting out of South
Stream so we need to if you like develop
something ahead of UD coming out with
South Stream so you've got a new
attitude to into so we've built the
program around you decanting out of
certain sites moving into a new site and
then disposing at that site and all the
time being mindful of the impact on the
community and trying to keep those
community users can yes it's going to
currently got them which is the approach
as well as trying to maximize the
benefit from the site and then using
that capital in line with your asset
strategy to basically invest that couple
back into re providing
you need new council HQ this so you've
been careful now we just check that
program to try and get the money flowing
as efficiently as possible in terms of
the financial care so the financial case
has two elements so this green is this
sought this is all about isn't
affordable and ours it going to be
funded there's two elements of any
financial analysis there's a capital
piece and there's a revenue piece so
that capital piece basically knocks out
the cost being a provision of the EU
council edge Q with capital receipt and
you see there's still a net requirement
from the council so there's still in
that requirement of about six hundred
care what the peak net requirement is
about 1.4 million so the receipts that
come in a slightly netted and you
actually need them so we need we need to
build a new hedge queue then dispose of
sub sites and then I must refrain
yourselves so there's a peak investment
by the council of about like four point
five and then in that overall
requirements have just over six hundred
thousand so options for the council
around funding that must be existing
council reserves are long term council
borrowing so you've got options we then
look at it in terms of a revenue cost of
the council and compare that to that
what you will classes that this option
or that do minimal function so that do
minimum option it would run along and
you can see there as at all or if you
like at all thirty-year cost of about
sixteen point four million compared to
the preferred scheme of about seven
point six million that's the thirty-year
cost it's probably probably my report on
on that annual basis if and when the
cash flow is calm down in it and the
projects completed the council's around
about three hundred thousand pounds per
year better off doing that option the
investment option
compared to luck to human emotion and
those those savings are largely linked
to not learning the lesser affirmations
as the album the current basis and not
maintaining if you like an oversized to
stay so it's a smaller stairs men tend
to industry standards so against
industry benchmarks what you maintain a
small understand and you're not having
to invest in the backlog repairs and
that basically that catch up to bring
you the stay up to a level so it is
there's the potential to generate so
there's a few elements of this the first
piece of the governance structure fall
or how do you procure this project and
having your key decisions so the
structure is there bills on your
existing governance models so when we
stop procure these projects for local
authorities we drive while with them to
proper governance structuring that
doctors sit within what already exists
so it's too it's too difficult and it
shouldn't require any changes to make
system structures but we try and get a
structures well that still allows the
officers to make decisions during the
procurement process but all was out the
checks and balances in place that the
council needs and always coming back to
full Council or cabinet or the
equivalent for those big decisions those
big sign-off decisions but really what
so not one that relies on there's a the
senior responsible officer there in the
center a new program border to the left
so the program board making heels during
the procurement but not the units of
acting acting is a check and balance we
to the project
teams of people who were willing to
procurement you've got the project
director and the project team there to
the rights of actually did today
dealings with the procurement me and the
developers asking all the questions
probing the developers in the prison the
bids still won't work for member party
so all the import that they've given us
today has been fantastic really
challenged us on of the options in the
meetings refining and skull and those
options so they're playing important
well if you like drive in that project
director in the project team and then
still at our top level er is still
adjusting your decision-making board so
this board and and full cop council
still making those overall big decisions
on because it was the winner with the
procurement signing off the scoring that
so I think you know over the period of
just out if you like some of the project
get ways to where we're at now approval
for BC obviously was to fall council
work oh yeah
approval of project outs and the
valuation reward is that is that senior
responsible officer well then you
approval will they want an investment
board so we move through the procurement
of issue and the orgy which is the form
of notice to start the procurement we
want to pre kuk um exercise which is to
solve if you like now or the field of
bidders and started to put so many
bidders through to the formal process to
some detail to submit detailed bids and
then the senior responsible officer will
be involved in up and sewing up making
that position to make the final time to
request what that one role approval I
think the point now is we do an award
anything that we don't move to agree the
decision
so all the checks and balances are in
place the welcome and all the major
decisions are still made up for senior
the last piece we wanted to touch on on
the management case is this sort of
skills incapacity point and it's I
suppose from working with the council is
limited capacity with me and within the
existing team to take a project forward
of this size and it's perfectly normal
for authorities to come to people like
us and a little advisors to basically
help through this through through which
one can work to procure it see you get
the skills that you need you get them
from a period of time you don't go out
to the market and recruit people that
you don't have to if you like you need
them in 12 months time so the council's
you to people like ourselves and legal
advisers and design advice to basically
bring that expertise that can be ramped
up and switch down which is a much more
efficient process than going into the
market and trying to recruit people
really so it's a lower cost overall it's
a flexible liberal resource and really
it's giving you the skills I present
when you need them through that
community it is common for authorities
to tap
and just I know there's a lot of
information there but just to sort of
summarize those five cases and where
we've been through all the last few
months for business case we've very
strong import from them and the working
party we've gone through a number of
options and must discard and the
president's options so we've turned that
into an integrated development program
really in line with that asset strategy
to try and reinvest couple and when it's
available and tries to tries to use your
own resources where possible all the
time looking at that long term reduction
in revenue cost and trying to protect
the council's long-term financial
position again then Lincoln with your
economic strategies of regenerating
where possible and having as much impact
on those town centers as we can and what
we've put together is what we would call
and we've you know we've we've set our
to no it's an aggressive procurement
timetable so we said we want to try and
do it in 12 months and that is
aggressive but we've mapped it out in
detail and if we should work with good
development partners who come on board
and invest when we want them to invest
then we think we can do it in 12 months
and that is usually a multidisciplinary
team the council together be working
and that is that is it's the business
case in summary there's a lot of nerve
and there's a lot in the business case
there's a lot of detail than I thought
thank you ma'am I believe you're going
to do a little bit answer numbers of
questions here hi I'm chairman would you
like me to do this in this state all do
coming in to this point just to thank
you chairman when you said the tenders
you're going to be filtering through the
Chamber's how many actually tenders
would you expect to bring to Investment
Board usually I mean it's it's different
for every project so that pqq stage
what's called the pre-qualification
questionnaire
sometimes we can get as many as 20 or 30
and some people bidding don't reason to
start the project and the idea with the
pqq stuffing that right down a good
procurement for me would be returned to
b3 through to that detailed stage
because we have to bear in mind enough
detail stage it requires a bit of
investment from bidders we don't want to
take too many through because it will
put some bitters off spending all that
money in competition so three won't be
good okay and the second one that
regeneration grants have we look to
regeneration also if you mentioned
regeneration we know that they are
available are we looking to bid for some
because I know there's some around there
about 40 million pounds that we can go
for we haven't as yet so when I
mentioned regeneration it's more about
economic impact of us on the town
centers but yeah if there's grants
available then so I assume that that is
something that we'll be looking to do a
live class II know I'm sure Network it's
somebody that it's for chairman
certainly at the right time senator
I kind of do I'm not member those early
and there's just two questions for money
which should be proven one is them
obviously with regard to a business plan
yes it delivery should be to maximize
our assets and also at the end of it it
doesn't mention about with social
purpose common beings outwardly but it
mentions about we should be doing social
purpose I couldn't find much about
social purpose in what we're doing with
this so and that concerns me in the
especially maximizing our assets in
regard to social progress which I could
take has been building social housing
for instance you might be taken by other
people other ways and so that's one of
the concerns delicous Ernie's the one on
right to the last meeting when I take on
board the comments which would make I
think as a couple make them equitably
which is around the fact that our
working practices would be improved be
the new building of go ahead and that
could make things more efficient up to
understand that but I do we keep making
that I keep seeing the figures here of
three hundred thousand I see three
hundred thirty thousand pounds
based on the three hundred thirty
thousand pounds saving per year based on
the fact that they're running costs of
the existing asset portfolio would rise
the owner running cost of rise to five
hundred eighty eight thousand department
lights make is that it we we could make
two hundred sixty seven thousand pounds
worth of annual savings just by setting
the frame house and the mill form so it
and I don't just as everyone's been for
so about the family we're putting this
for three hundred two thousand pound
plus
front of one of the reasons for doing
this where's because they've virtually
the same we've not the same by just
saying the two of the properties and
I'll take a board the Faculty's not
doing other items within it but I think
when we try to make was the fact about
the saving is three and two thousand
that the with failing to point out that
just by saying two properties and
leaving everything else to say would
make the same savings birch Street
Charlie if I may comment on the on the
first couple points in the o me will
they Mabel are coming on the second
point in terms of the the social aspects
social focus thank you in terms that the
the appraisers have been based on a
policy compliant basis in terms of
affordable housing so it's been based at
that level in terms of the facilities
themselves in Samsa palatial facilities
it's if you to improve those facilities
so newer high quality facilities for
residents to use a better chamber space
flexible space horrible space there's
ban in pre facilities and we tried to
pull out the business plan thank you
just one point if I'm a chairman and
then a clarification on something as far
as the projects are concerned we would
meet all costs etcetera from existing
funds and we're not visiting any
borrowing can you just clarify that for
me yes so that the IBC sets out what we
are supposed music which to the public
section yeah yeah and that overall there
would be a net cost and based on our
current assumptions of around six
hundred thousand pounds to fund the
program and as mentioned in the
presentation that would be the cash
flows realized from the receipts of the
us it might not necessarily be before
we've actually had to spend the money to
invest in the new buildings however that
would be a short flow cash requirement
and as we said we either do some
short-term borrowing or use our reserves
and we've got sufficient reserves in
place at the moment to fund to bridge
that gap so we wouldn't actually
necessarily have to add that undertake
any borrowing to actually follow the
program at that stage although we may
choose to depending on what the plan
answers to looking like but yeah there
would be a net overall cost of six
hundred thousand pounds by as we said we
can envisage we could fund that from our
reserves currently so it wouldn't be a
requirement boring but if we if we chose
to we could choose to borrow instead of
using
but that decision would be made at the
relevant point in time continued
chairman the artist looking and that
it's been provided to me about the Local
Government Act 1972 which is the general
disposal consent England 9 2003 and it
talks about the disposal this is the
local authority consider the planning
the land is to be disposed it's like to
contribute to the achievement that any
one or more of the following objects in
respect to the whole and part of its
area or all or any persons resident in
present in the era what and the first
one is the promotional improvement of
economic well-being
the second is promotional improvement of
social well-being and third is emotion
improvement that we've our own mental
will be well of course we are providing
facilities through what we have planning
chairmen and improving the facilities
that we are actually offering at the
moment so I think the you know the
social side of what we're doing I think
is self-evident in what we see in front
of us thank you to the Chairman's come
back on counter couple other point the
council also of course has a doctor
disposal framework which actually refers
to that very act that counter cut them
all was referring to it sets out the
framework for doing that agreed by
opposed activism in light of the severe
shortage of consumer control housing
right otherwise it was this I reading
the pool stop me if you think I'm
actually encroaching on the exempt
because it is a bit of a fallen line
there is consideration that has been
given to this but it's been dismissed
immediately because of the issue of the
possibility of option to by the figures
on council prophecies council own home
and you know council own homes in an
article that was in the New Statesman
recently up until the 80s governments of
all colors were developing
houses to the tune of around about
240,000 year last year it was 6,000 and
then we wonder why we've got a
homelessness problem we have a a chance
here to actually address that issue yes
I know that we do have the problem of
the headache of possible by a right to
buy but did we use that as a reason for
actually passing off the chance to
produce social hodgins social housing
all the time because it's very easy to
and we are not contributing then to the
social needs of the area by missing
opportunity here Jim I I can start
college may wish to come as well in
terms of the the housing stock question
I know the short simple answer would be
as members be aware we don't have a
housing revenue account therefore we
couldn't hold housing stock in that way
but have to look at a different model
which would be wholly outside the
countless current operations or
experience in terms of the financing of
that they'll probably again go beyond
and potentially above something that
would be recommended and no me may wish
to come in attempt us a scale and size
of that sort development anyway was to
comment actually hold housing stock in
it and directly and it would happily do
that that is one of the options that was
originally considered through project
why burn and this map said in order to
make the financial said that stack up
you'd have to work on a much larger
scale than probably the development size
that we're looking at so we can really
financially make that work on paper when
we consider that option previously and
that's it also operationally we're not
set up to actually run a housing company
at the moment so it would involve a
whole new skill set and hold a whole
news of a way of working for the council
which which would be a significant sort
of shift of business from what we're
doing at the moment and what we have
said is that obviously when the site's
come up for disposal
supposin strategy that housing providers
would be given sort of first option to
look at those sites and see whether they
are in a position to they're not grown
and develop those sites for their own
for their own use and then be like it is
that at least some of the sites would be
developed for housing whether the
private sector or freely of educator and
social landlords but asthmatic we don't
feel it's the right option for us and as
a council directly talk to its bad
opinion operator housing look at this
time this was actually discussed by the
Working Party I'll just be reminded they
have looked into this quite deeply I
don't know if the world probably wants
to comment on that one no I mean I think
I think of this is pretty much covered
German yeah can I just come back on that
Matt did say that we'd have to adopt a
different we have to okay so what how
different with the model be to be able
to encompass that I appreciate you the
Working Party have looked at this but we
as a committee haven't been involved in
that I think it's right so it would have
to operate for a private and company and
so that essentially be a wholly owned
and company off the council but if it
should have to operate in a private
sector model so paying the relevant
taxes and it would have to sort of with
the council a shareholder would have to
do and ensure it's not actually buying
and you can't meet its obligations to
the council and I think when we looked
that before is to say we can actually
make that as a model the size that we're
looking at all right you know I just
want to make a major point in the first
week of February a health check will be
conducted on the asset delivery program
this will be conducted by the local
partnership assurance group the remember
member
of the working party myself and the
officers will be interviewed by the
invited partnership assurance team which
was pacified some of the questions which
were raised in the last investment board
game caster standing
thank you but could I have an Austin to
the second question there counselor who
else please
and then I'll get to one question I
can't so I repeat the question please
just for clarity there's more things
that I thank you Jim
South Street is quoted on strings yes it
has got old buildings in it and such and
in 2020 we're presenting ie or
delivering an exercise that will
encompass that straight as well as it's
quite an old one and it's something
which is of interest to the whole
community there's already been mounted
that the boy bone project incomes of
didn't come to fruition for one reason
or another and yet we spend an awful lot
of money on that how do we know that the
risk that we're taking or developers
that are coming in will meet that risk
we're always saying that we want an ia
plus plus plus plus plus as far as we
can do when we do risk management's what
is the risk management of this which
hasn't been I haven't seen it in the
notes anywhere from there's the the
official times that we've been from
Glade of what have you what is the risk
management on that and the amount of
money that of 625 K that we would have
to put up if I remember rightly
incorrectly on this I thought the IT was
only half that amount that yet it's gone
to six hundred and eighty thousand which
I have doubts that this such 625 will be
the last number that we're dealing with
it could be a lot lot more than what we
actually anticipate there boy
their funds will be going down
drastically the other thing is that is
it the maintenance that hasn't been done
over the years that the cancer event
these properties that there is such
disrepair that they need to be knocked
down or whatever the cases to be sown
and if that's the case what the savings
have we made if we haven't worked on
them as I we must have an officer that
does building survey and we must have
something that gives us ideas over the
year per year of what we have to spend
to keep them up to scratch I've got a
couple of questions from crying keep on
my up most those can we take those if I
take the first in chairman it this is
where I'm risking and our approach to
risk leave may wish to come in
afterwards but in terms of the wave
approaches and two ways that's at risk
of the project and optimism bias and I
think it's appendix D unbelievable to
double-check use within the OVC it sets
out a table of how all the risks have
been addressed and then mitigated
against and then terms of optimism
buyers who've used again standards
Treasury guidance applying her
percentage to identified risk which is
added which is attached in a number to
that area of risk which is basically
increase those figures to what you see
today to that risk has been taken
account for mitigated against we
eventually another work previously a
project why burn for example to some of
those risk nots and buyers has been
moved to take into account some of the
early work we've done so that's why you
see sonamoo than the optimism bias
through the tables but so it's been a
very prudent approach through risk
management I'm not to his implying
through the project hey question
it's very quick yeah there's only to go
pop this three actually but from what
Craig has asked me to mention if you
don't mind chairman what is being
proposed for the mill Hall with regard
to laser physicist services as part of
the preferred option that's option 2
with FRA airs its own cleared could you
clarify then there have been concerns
throughout this that this doesn't really
feel like an investment more like an
asset sale he but I have been cautiously
proceeding whilst this was phrased as a
cost neutral way about looking potential
assets this report now reveals that is
unlikely to be cost neutral now along
with the cell with the for our DC sites
and the last question is considering the
DeMars of this program are specifically
greater than previously attempted by the
council one one page six point two five
the cost will be the loss of four sites
and potentially 625,000 in funds is the
recommended solution proportionate to
the problem so we'll take the first
question regarding the male arts event
center site the report paragraph nine
point four sets out that the plan for
that site as we said it's about
redeveloping the site but retaining a
suitable portion on the ground floor for
community uses so if they're bullying
that in again that's some a challenge
we've had with the Working Party about
how to get that offer right at that site
in terms of community in terms which may
wish to come in on the I think we may
have our to some of these in terms of
fine others but happy to I think it
might be right at the moment I'm showing
a net cost
say that builds in all the relevant
results in device numbers so that that
could change that sort of the most pujan
assumption we've got to work with at the
moment that is the net capital loss but
success is when the net present value
basis is office the best long-term value
for the council as these safety because
we can generate a reduction in of each
cost around three hundred thousand
pounds a year so it's it's not just
about how much the net capital positive
them great in the new outfit it's
actually about ensuring the financial
sustainability of the counseling to the
longer term as well so that's all you
get is the best value option accounted
first of all when we look at the
financial impact for the council there
is a capital funding gap in terms of one
we look at that revenue position the
council do i hope the council do have
options of our using capital reserves
are using borrowing when we look at the
revenue position we assume a new borrow
it
it's just the standard aware that we
would look at it so we we build in the
revenue cause to be servicing that debt
so really from i know you guys you look
a couple of revenue the main driver when
we look up these projects is that with a
long-term revenue survey which can you
invest some capital are the reserves are
borrowing and what we turn to you've
gone that investment in really that in
turn what we're showing them against the
do minimum is about 300k if you looked
at it from a pair back point of view
it's two years so in two years you'll
get the 600 k investment this is so I
mean this issue regarding community
space was one of the big concerns we've
had at the mule ball
I think we've made it very very clear
that we you know we obviously understand
that there's got to be a community
helper point of contact me for a
district council we believe and this we
can only go to a certain point here but
we've made very clear that
future we've got to look at having wraps
there Citizens Advice any other aspect
that we feel would be appropriate we
don't know what's going to come down the
road we don't know if County my approach
is to get involved in certain aspects
but the flexibility of the space is such
now as as as good as explained to us
that you can make these areas as large
and or as small as as you actually want
them and this is where we've said that
you may need to bring other people in
with different skill sets who know or
have a better understanding of what the
community different play area of play
groups or whatever what they will need
how you could use your flexibility to do
this so this is one of the very areas
that we've been quite quite strongly
stated to to both officers and
consultants that this is why you need to
work group involved and last but not
least we've made the point that the town
that the mill Hall is in the town and
this is where residents want to come
they do not want to go all over Riley
it's a town center location and this is
where the community wants to wants to
meet I mean I say that's County issues
with County we all know what they're
some of their ideas are at the moment
that that might be an area where they
don't want to become involved as world
look but nothing's set in stone the
flexibility is there to do what we want
to do as the years move on castle wall
it was just all on the point that came
across from from Chris actually with
regard to some of the items on the in
fact we ended on only bit I'm gonna let
it go for the moment yeah it's easier
just Lee's thank you
the issue of risk has been brought up
again you won't be surprised to know
that I'm still very uneasy with the
direction that this is taking I am
concerned that I've read the reports or
not I have to say that
a very thorough and I've had no no
argument with that but they do seem to
read as though they have come from the
point of view we've made the decision so
let's make the reports fit the decision
let me explain
one of the things that's been discounted
early is so good now sorry itself built
the reasons why they have been
discounted do actually allow him what is
happening in the building industry at
this moment I'm sure the council's who
trusted Corinne Ian thought that they
were getting into a good setup the fact
of the matter ease the big companies at
the moment I spoke to a friend of mine
to be a director of building company in
London about 250 million pound turnover
and they do a lot of public contracts
they run what they call a distressed
contracted list now the problem he said
that he has in his business with that is
that on the face of it a lot of
contractors look and have cooks that
sound very good but the fact is that
what happens in big contracts is that
you have issues where at the end of the
contract nine times out of ten there are
extras and they are large those extras
are nine times out of ten in dispute
what actually happens to keep the books
white of these companies is that they
will actually declare that when they are
going to litigation excellence is a
million pounds mitigation they will say
that they expect to get eight hundred
thousand of that that will appear in
their books when in actual fact they
don't get a penny of it so it is a false
shot we know you might say what actually
is happening now this is not this is
something that is actually central
government
Arnel recognizing i don't know if all of
you have had an email today but I had
one coming from Westminster briefing and
they are calling us to go up to a
briefing which one of the bullet points
on there is diverted to develop
effective strategies to transfer
previously outsourced
contracts back in-house for this very
reason that big companies have actually
become an issue what I find strange is
that we seem to have had an appetite to
produce new businesses Green gateway and
encourage that but when we have an
opportunity to go in a in a direction
that I believe is actually a lesser risk
than the one we're looking at that we
are giving away the opportunity of
generating into the capital another
million pounds by going down the
self-build route which is the biggest
that we presented to us last time around
the problem is that what people don't
seem to understand in the building
industry is that the success of a
building contract is not necessarily
down to the company it's down to the
contract manager the contracts manager
that you have on a job is key now in
procurement if you actually brought this
in-house and you did your due diligence
in finding someone who had a track
record and was very good at doing
contract management and actually had
history I think is it personally being
in the building history I find one I
think it's a no-brainer
I understand why you're going down this
route because it's an easy woman okay
sorry can you get to your question
please why are we going down this route
and ignoring completely they so good I
think just sort of elements of that
question I'd agree that the
and local authorities are started to
question and unpick large organizations
like what coupling it was and there's a
general nervousness in the industry
about some of those larger organizations
who took on massive contracts and some
of those contracts were high risk so
things like Liverpool Hospital and so
many other projects that impacted
chameleons and there's a nervousness
definitely in the public sector around
awarding long term outsourcing contracts
so these long term outsourcing FM
contracts on construction cost our
contracts dock Karelian and some of the
others were given so that I agreed up
nervousness is there there's a
nervousness with the financial
statements that they've produced in that
time partly I think and it's just that
nervousness in the industry is that and
I think all we can do to assess that
really is as part of our pgq process we
do review their financial statements and
we assess how much cash they've got in
the bank the projects that delivered in
that regard
I wouldn't expect we would be dealing
with organizations the size of some of
the ones we've mentioned on this like
the issue about self-build generally I
mean we do speak to local authorities
who are what you would call self
building untaken direct development risk
but those are generally - probably a bit
larger than yourselves they've built up
a bit of a track record in it and I
think the issue with self build on this
partly is and there's development risk
there in terms of sales risk at the end
so would be being really self develop in
residential units on some other sites
and then marketing and selling those
residential units and that is quite a
special ism and I've been the reason
that the financials are differential
between you doing it and a developer is
in the financial analysis we've assumed
the developer wants to take 15-20
percent profit out of it which is
commencement another level of risk for
taken and I just think from our point of
view
working with yourselves and the size of
the authority that would be a big risk
for the authorities
to self-build those developments out and
then say if you like demand risk in
sales risk at the end of development it
would certainly do that a couple of
receipts coming in and cross funding
this construction of your new Civic and
it I mean from our point of view if we
would class it as high risk from an
authority vo sighs to be good cattleman
Thank You chairman my question relates
around facilities and services over the
project period now it would seem that
there's a strong likelihood that
facilities and services to our residents
may be limited restricts it diminished
during potentially during the project
period but may be continuing afterwards
as well because of a lack of lack of
facilities that may be available or he
gives the council the opportunity to
produce those facilities
if he chooses to do so as part of
cutbacks
has there been any detailed planning as
to what what is going to you know fill
the spaces of where there's going to be
changes or to work where the assets are
going to be exposed of another what's
going to happen in this state and so
chairman did the outline business case
that the exemplar for sets out and some
things out in terms of what the spaces
are looking like but again through that
a competitor dialogue processes cancer
and disturb Sparrow referred to that
would be tested and explore so those
options will still be tested through
that process but down our business case
does sets out some detail questions
intersection shall we go through the
questions which we presented I need
going to P and C first okay on that
basis okay check if I made a Blee Blee
probably answered most those questions
as we're taking the earlier questions
and that session I believe you can
answer those questions now ed members
that we have answered and clearly we've
responded the most of my belief if we'd
like to respond those I think we could
do that now
oh you can see in it no we're not okay
okay there were just a couple of other
questions that I actually had when it
comes to the self build whether any
projects that you'd actually looked at
to compare to see whether it was worth
our while going down that road and what
evidence do you have of those projects
okay move to the PSA them okay
just to read the exclusion resolution
and public the following report contains
exempt information
he is hereby resolved another section or
disclosure of information
I'm paragraph three of one of schedule
twelve area just to remind take the
recommendations individually post all
the songs to recommend to for Council
the count like business case for the
asset delivery program and the exact
appendix to the report to be approved
and published with appropriate reduction
is everybody those in favor please
any against number two there's noting
that in line with the council's
financial regulation section one find
one officer in conjunction with the
leader or the council has authorized
twenty four thousand five hundred pound
to be drawn down from the general
balances to fund the Vice do to advise
due diligence works required before the
cumin phrase can commence
well those agree against item three to
recommend two for Council that are
further four hundred and ninety eight
thousand two hundred pound was drawn
down as we need emerald balancing to
fund the resources required to process
the program to full business case stage
those in favor and against
the asset delivery program we progress
through procurement process to select
and the draft into a full business case
in conjunct consultation with the member
working class all those in favor okay
item five that the introduction of a
project bulletins be no no - okay thank
you everybody
the officers were you know saving